du haut de sa moissonneuse guillaume
envoie la fin la fin de la récolte des
lentilles du berry après les avoir semé
en avril les terres sèches de juillet
sont propices au ramassage quand elles
sont amarrés à maturité au lait lait
récoltés pour pas les laisser trop
longtemps
plus elles vont sécher - elle se ramasse
facilement avec une moissonneuse
batteuse comme guillaume ils sont
cinquante agriculteurs répartis sur 900
hectares dans le berry à cultiver la
lentille cette année il espère en
ramasser 1800 tonnes soit une
augmentation de près de 40% par rapport
à l'année passée
tous les éléments étaient réunis pour
favoriser une récolte exceptionnelle
l'année 2018 sera une est une bonne
récolte au niveau quantité et au niveau
qualité du fait de la climatologie qui a
été propice pour pour la culture de
lentilles une fois ramassés la lentille
est acheminée dans cet entrepôt où elle
est traitée emballés avant d'être
expédié une lentilles vertes du berry
qui tient sa renommée d'un label obtenu
il ya déjà vingt ans pour se démarquer
de la masse de canada d'experts
d'importation de lentilles du canada on
a voulu faire un produit se
différenciait faire un produit de
qualité donc on est parti sur un label
rouge et après sur une identification
géographique protégée les gp qui est un
signe européen pour vraiment se
démarquer et faire après qu'elle était
cahier des charges au niveau du berry
plus connus comme plat d'hiver la
lentilles vertes du berry se déguste
également en salade
même en été en vinaigrette ou à
l'échalote